SPEAKER 1: Hello.
We'd like to welcome Lisa
Lewtan this afternoon
to "Talks at Google."
Lisa is a health and lifestyle
coach, the founder of Healthy,
Happy, and Hip, an
award winning author,
and a host of "Busy, Stressed,
and Food Obsessed Radio"
at VoiceAmerica.com, which
is named after her book.
Using the skills she developed
as a successful technology
entrepreneur, Lisa self
hacked her own mind and body
to restore her health and then
go on to feel better than ever.
With private coaching,
online courses, workshops,
and retreats, Lisa
helps highly successful
go getters to slow down,
chill out, develop a better
relationship with
food and stress,
look good, and feel great.
To learn more, you can visit
healthyhappyandhip.com.
Welcome, Lisa.
LISA LEWTAN: Thank you, Joyce.
Was there ever a time
of your life where
you thought you were so cool,
only to look back and think,
was I out of my mind?
For me, it was August, 1994.
I was 31 years old.
I see you doing the math.
I had just had my
second baby, and I
was working at a tech company.
It was a tech company that I
co-founded with my boyfriend,
who, yes, was now my husband.
We just moved into our
first house in the suburbs.
There I was in my new house,
nursing my newborn baby son.
I had a phone kind of stuck
in between my shoulder
and my head, because I had a
few things going on at work that
just couldn't wait till later.
And I had my arm pointing
to some BU students
that I just hired for the day
to help unpack some boxes so
that I could focus
on the office, all
while my daughter was--
I don't know-- reading
"Goodnight Moon" or something
by my leg.
It was multitasking
at its finest.
I had mastered it.
Woohoo!
Three days later, I ended
up in the emergency room,
and my life would
never be the same.
I'm here today to share
my story with you.
It's a story that I
talk about in my book,
and it's a story that eventually
led me to write the book.
And it's a story that could
actually change your life.
Let's go back to the beginning.
I grew up in New York.
I was one of four kids--
two girls and two boys.
And in my family,
they didn't care
about how rich somebody was
or how pretty they were.
It was all about
how smart they were.
I think it was an
Eastern European thing.
Anyway, it was very
clear also in my family
that the boys were really smart.
I was smart, but
they were smarter.
And truth be told,
they were really smart.
One ended up going to
MIT, and the other one
ended up at Wharton.
And it made me feel like,
even though I was smart,
I just never was going
to be smart enough.
Another thing in my
family-- and maybe
you can relate to this one--
was tears were weakness.
Keep it together.
Hold it together.
Be tough.
And so when my report
card would come
and I'd take the walk of
shame to my dad's office,
and I'd be holding back the
tears because I got a B,
I learned how to not cry, to
be tough, keep it all together.
I had a lot of
ambition growing up.
I wanted to be
somebody really big.
But I always remember
my parents saying to me,
don't get your
hopes up too high.
You might be disappointed.
And another thing
that they always
said to me again and again
was don't be a quitter.
And I took these things
very much to heart
and carried them with me.
And so by the time I got
to be an adolescent I just
didn't feel so great.
I thought about it.
I was smart, but
not smart enough.
And I was skinny, but that felt
not that interesting to me.
I looked around at the
other kids at school,
and they were athletes,
and dancers, and musicians,
and I was none of those things,
and I felt that I was not
good at anything.
In fact, I thought I
was inherently boring.
I might even be the most boring
person on the entire planet,
I thought.
And I can laugh about
that now, but at the time
as an adolescent it was
extraordinarily painful.
I literally felt like I
had a big sign on my head.
You're not good enough.
You're boring.
You're a loser.
And I know you know
what I'm talking about,
because we all have that
I'm not good enough thing
in some flavor or another.
And so I needed to hide
because these feelings were
so painful for me, and I didn't
know what to do with them.
And so I started to
get busy, and I just
started doing more
and more things.
And it was fascinating
because the more things I did,
the less time I had
to think about all
those horrible thoughts.
And then something
else amazing happened.
I had all these cool
things to talk about
because I was doing
so many things.
It was like this crazy win-win.
And so by the end of high
school, I was a class officer.
I was working at Szechuan
Cuisine Chinese takeout.
I was on kick line.
I was planning the prom.
I was founder of the
Greco Roman Culture Club.
I was that annoying girl that
was in charge of everything,
and you know what?
I was finally good at something.
And so around the same
time, I started getting
these weird mystery ailments.
Started off first there were
hives that would come and go--
really itchy red things--
and my mom would say, oh,
it's just stress, honey.
Don't worry about it.
Later on, I started getting
these horrible stomachaches.
Yes, worse than
childbirth, I can say now.
And I would be rushed
to the hospital.
They would do tests and
tests, and I'd start vomiting
violently all over the place,
and they thought my appendix
burst, but it hadn't.
And they didn't know what was
wrong, and they'd send me home.
And my mom would say, it's
probably just stress, honey.
And so I learned that
stress was something
that wasn't a big deal.
Stress was something that
could just be ignored.
I went off to college,
which I've now
renamed Superwoman
Training Academy,
because while my friends were
out partying and having fun,
I was majoring in being busy.
By the time I was a
senior in college,
I was going to school full time.
I had three separate part time
jobs totaling over 40 hours
a week.
I took a class at
another college
nearby in fashion just for
fun, because I liked it,
and they didn't offer
it at my college.
And my roommate and
I were designing
these decorative accessories
just for fun on the side.
I was insane, but
it was the only way
to stay sane for me
because it helped
me distract all those
awful feelings of I'm
not good enough.
And I had so much to prove.
I thought it was to my parents,
but it was really to me--
that I was smart enough,
and that I could suck it in,
and that I was going
to be somebody,
and I wasn't going
to be a quitter.
Luckily, I learned
how to ignore stress.
Well, it worked out really
well, because a year after I
graduated college, I
was selling software
to the fashion industry in New
York-- two things that I loved.
My boyfriend-- he was
up here in Boston,
and he quit his banking job,
and he started teaching himself
a new thing called dBase III.
It was on an IBM PC, and these
were pretty new around then.
And so when the bank hired
him back as a consultant,
he got this project
that was going on,
and he got tired of our back
and forth New York-Boston thing.
So he said, please,
please, please
move to Boston
just for one year.
I promise we'll move to New
York when it's all over.
Now, I loved my job,
and I loved New York.
But I loved my boyfriend,
and so off I moved.
There was no tech for the
fashion industry in Boston,
and the tech for other
industries at that time
was for mainframe computing
and mini computers.
It was really boring.
So I went to the headhunters
and said, I can sell.
What can you find me?
And they said, come work for us.
No, I wasn't interested.
And so when my boyfriend
said, "I think other people
might need databases.
This is kind of a new thing.
Can you help me
sell my services?"
I thought, eh,
it's for one year.
What the hell?
And so I said sure.
And in 1986, Lewtan
Technologies was born.
I was 23 years old.
Stuart was working at
the Bank of Boston.
We hired a couple
of contractors,
and I set up our first office
at the Statler Office Building
in the Back Bay.
It was 200 square feet.
I had a desk.
I had a computer, and I had
a phone, and that was it.
The only software that we
had heard of at the time
was called Lotus 1-2-3 and
WordPerfect Word Processing.
That was it.
Can you imagine
life without Google?
So tech in the '80s was crazy.
We didn't have cell phones.
We didn't have email.
We didn't have laptops.
We didn't have Google.
I can't even imagine
our life before Google.
And we didn't have respect.
Today, when kids in their
20s start a tech company,
venture capitalists
are like, woo hoo.
Not then.
We would walk into a
meeting with bankers.
We had ended up in this field
called asset securitization.
It was this banking area.
We provided software.
They would look at us, and
they'd see these two kids,
and they would
walk out the door.
My superwoman training came
in really, really handy,
because as our company grew
from 20 people to 30 people,
I had to wear a lot of hats,
and I was doing everything.
I was doing sales and marketing,
contract negotiation--
because we were a
bootstrapped company,
and we couldn't afford lawyers.
I did the accounting
and the finance,
the hiring, human resources.
And let me tell you something.
When you have to hire
people-- really smart people--
to work really long hours,
for really little pay,
and no equity, that was tough.
But I did it.
I did all the
facilities planning
because we moved every
year, year and a half
as we were growing--
all the event planning.
It was endless.
And our typical days--
we would drag ourselves to work,
grab something at Au Bon Pain,
eat it at our desk,
bring in some pizza
because there were no
healthy options around.
Eat it at our desk.
Maybe go out to dinner at night.
Many nights, however,
truth be told,
we would get a pint of Ben and
Jerry's Phish Food ice cream
and eat it with two spoons.
And then we'd go, [VOCALIZING]
fall asleep, get up,
do it again, and again,
and again, and again.
The stress was relentless.
We had no free time at all.
Stuart worked seven days a week.
I worked six days a
week, and the day off I
was doing laundry
and paying bills--
nothing fun.
We didn't have any
time for friends,
which was a good thing,
because I didn't really
have any friends.
I moved to Boston.
Never had time to make any.
We didn't have any money because
all the money we were making we
were putting right back
in to fund our company.
There were times we even
went to our savings account
and took out our wedding
money to pay employees,
because quitting just
wasn't an option.
And we didn't have time for
fun, or rest, or self-care.
Now, truth be told, this was
the '80s, and I don't even know
if self-care existed--
the term-- but even if it
had, I wouldn't have done it
because I was too busy.
And then there was
the female factor.
Now, I know there's all
sorts of issues for women
now with equal
work and equal pay,
but there were other issues,
too, and I think many of them
still exist today.
I would go to these
banking conferences,
and there would be
500 men in the room,
and I would be the only woman.
Now, some women
might have thought,
hey, that's kind of
cool, but not me.
I looked around, and I
thought, I shouldn't be here.
I am not smart
enough to be here.
I want to be invisible.
And I literally walked
around like this.
I had no female mentors.
Women in my mother's
generation never worked.
Women my own age were
still in entry level jobs.
They weren't running
tech companies.
We didn't have networks.
We didn't have
online communities.
We had nothing.
And so I had that super
pressure that I put on myself.
Don't quit.
Suck it up.
Be somebody.
And I kept going, wearing
my superwoman cape,
and kept going, and going,
and going till I got pregnant.
I remember we'd finally
gotten interoffice email.
I emailed Stuart.
Just working on this proposal.
I swear it will be done
soon, and then we'll
get out of here, because the
contractions are starting.
We rushed to FedEx,
and we made it just
at the 7:00 PM cutoff, grabbed a
bite at a restaurant next door,
and the contractions
were going like crazy,
and 24 hours later,
I was a mother.
I was an exhausted,
terrified mother.
I was a mother who had
never changed a diaper.
My baby cried all the time.
She was hungry.
I was feeding her all the time.
I was a mess.
I was so tired and exhausted.
My husband looked at
me and thought, never
seen her like that before.
My mom, who had come to help,
looked at me and thought,
I've never seen her
like that before.
And so I hid in the
bathroom, pretending
that I was taking a sitz
bath, where I was really
negotiating a contract
with Ford Motor Corp
that I had left off
two days earlier.
Two weeks later, I
went to the doctor.
They looked at the baby,
and they looked at me.
They wrote on her chart,
"Failure to thrive."
Apparently I had
been so depleted
that I was starving my child.
I wasn't making any breast milk.
Although they wrote on her
chart, "Failure to thrive,"
the truth is I was
failing to thrive, too,
but I was too busy to notice.
I came back.
I rushed back to work
as soon as I can--
somewhere that I
could feel competent--
but things had been growing,
and I had a different role.
Suddenly we had hired two
people to take my job.
I couldn't travel.
I couldn't stay late.
I couldn't do all those things.
When I was at work, all I
could think about was my baby,
and when I was with my baby,
all I could think about
was I was screwing up at work.
I couldn't win.
On the outside, people
think, huh, what a hot shit.
Young, new child, running
this tech company--
woo hoo, she's got it together.
But on the inside, I was a mess.
I had no friends.
I had no life.
I was so sad.
I had no time for me, and I felt
like I just wasn't good enough.
It's just stress.
Don't be a quitter.
And so I kept going,
and going, and going.
And a couple of years later,
it was time for baby number two
and a new house.
There I was.
We had just moved
into our new house.
I was nursing my newborn son.
I had the phone in between
my head on my shoulder,
because, you know,
I had some stuff
to get done at the office.
My hand was pointing.
You know where I'm going, right?
But you don't know
how I got there.
Couple of days after we
moved into our house,
we packed up the
kids and we went down
to New York for my
brother-in-law's wedding.
My daughter was going
to be the flower girl.
My husband was the best man.
I stuffed my post-partum
body into that black gown.
I got the hair done.
I put on the lipstick,
the bracelet, the sandals.
And all of a sudden,
time stopped.
My hand started tingling.
It started moving up my arm.
I got really dizzy,
and I noticed
I couldn't see peripherally.
I was rushed to the
North Shore Hospital.
I was hysterical crying.
Here I was in this gown with
mascara streaming down my face.
I was a mess.
I had no idea.
I felt like I was an
alien in my own body.
I had always kept it together.
I always had been OK.
What the hell was going on?
I cried because my
daughter was so excited.
She was supposed to
be the flower girl.
And I cried because
my husband, who
was supposed to be the
best man, was right there,
and noticed he happened to have
the wedding ring in his hand.
I cried because I didn't
know what was going on,
and I was terrified.
Five hours later, the resident
said to me, a woman your age
can't lose her
peripheral vision.
I don't know what's
wrong with you.
Probably just stress.
I think you're going to be OK.
But I was not OK, and I
knew that I would not be OK.
And with those
words, he broke me.
For two years-- two whole
years after that night--
I had repeat incidents
again, and again, and again.
I called them wavy gravies.
They'd come, and
I'd get tingles.
I'd get lights.
I'd get dizzy and cry.
And then a minute
later I was fine.
And sometimes I had these
episodes up to 10 times a day.
Here I was.
I had a baby.
I had a toddler.
I had a new house.
I had a business.
And I had a husband who was
still working 80 hours a week.
What I didn't have
was any support.
I had no family anywhere nearby.
I had just moved,
and I had no friends.
I found somebody to
help with the kids,
but nobody to help with me.
It never occurred to me.
Doctors were frustrating
beyond belief.
They just couldn't tell
me what was wrong with me.
They kept writing
me prescriptions,
and I kept refusing to take them
because they couldn't tell me
what was wrong with me, and
it was driving me insane!
But because I was taught
don't be a quitter,
I kept going and going.
I kept going to work.
I kept going home.
I kept going through the
motions, all the while praying
that they would find a brain
tumor and just put me out
of my misery.
And it's around then
I met my best friend.
She was really sweet.
She was always there for me,
and if I just needed a break
or something, she showed up.
Always exactly what
I need her to be.
Her name was food.
Food has a way of
doing that, doesn't it?
It can be your confidant,
your best friend, your lover--
whatever you want it to be.
And for some people
it's not food.
For some people, it's wine,
or shopping, or gambling.
For me, food came
at the right time.
I started thinking
about food all the time.
Breakfast, I started
thinking about lunch.
At lunch, I started
thinking about dinner.
It became a source
of pleasure for me.
It wasn't that I was
eating it all the time,
but I was thinking--
I was obsessing about
it all the time.
It was like there was
an Instagram feed going
through my brain of
delicious yummy things
that I could dream about.
It was pleasure.
It was this fantasy world
in a world that seemed
too hard for me to deal with.
I eventually got
tired of being tired.
I got sick of being sick.
I thought to myself,
there's no Web MD.
There's no Google.
I didn't think that then,
but I'm thinking that now.
What am I going to do?
And then it occurred to me.
I'm an entrepreneur.
We come up with
creative solutions.
And so I took the matters
into my own hands,
and I looked at
it like a project.
I started reading
books-- books, and books,
and books on
anything that I could
find related to the topic.
I looked at the prescriptions
that the doctors
had prescribed,
trying to understand
what it was that
they hadn't meant
to treat in the first place.
Xanax?
What?
I was so confused.
I researched family histories.
Grandma had a nervous breakdown?
I was so confused, but I started
connecting dots, and connecting
more and more dots, and then
the craziest thing happened.
Somebody told me there's
this weird thing that
happens called an ocular
migraine-- that you
get these flashing
lights and weird stuff.
And so I started
reading about migraines.
And in this one book about
migraines by Oliver Sacks,
it said people who get migraines
when they're adults sometimes
had stomachaches when
they were teenagers
where they would get
very violent stomachaches
with vomiting.
And I was like, oh my god!
The first mystery ever
of my life was solved.
I called up my
parents screaming,
and then I knew from that moment
that every single thing had
gone on in my body-- there
was an answer for it,
and I was going to find it.
I started planning experiments,
and I figured it out.
In my case, I had
severe exhaustion.
Duh.
I had crippling anxiety.
Who know?
I always sucked it up.
And this weird disposition to
migraines-- now, in my case,
it was ocular, abdominal.
I never even had a headache.
But so now that I knew
what had gone wrong,
how did I make it right?
There were no coaches.
There were no books
on this stuff.
There was no Google.
And so I thought, I need to
just start experimenting.
Of course I was
still going to work,
still taking care of my kids.
And I started paying
attention to my own body.
I started experimenting-- food,
and stress, and breathing,
and relaxation, and
positive thinking.
And you name it, I paid
attention, and I experimented.
I hacked it.
Now, you'll notice I separated
sugar from food, because I
don't think of sugar as a food.
I think of sugar as a drug--
a very powerful drug.
And I figured out that I kind
of needed to slow down and stop
being a super hero.
Now, you might think
that's really obvious,
but it's never obvious
to ourselves, right?
It's obvious to
everyone around us.
This was shocking for me.
It never even occurred to me.
And what a difference it made.
Stopped getting
the wavy gravies.
I had more energy, joy.
I had a third baby.
And it was finally time
for me, after 12 years,
to leave Lewtan Technologies.
I continued my hacking,
and I continued my passion
with health and wellness.
And eventually I said,
I'm going back to school.
I studied holistic
nutrition, and I became
a health and lifestyle coach.
But three months into
going back to school,
the strangest thing happened.
Clients started showing up.
They were successful,
powerful go getters.
They were so smart, but they
didn't know how to relax.
They didn't know
how to calm down.
They didn't know how to take
care of themselves, in a way,
and thought they
might be burning out.
Sound familiar?
And I understood it
in a way-- in a way
that only somebody
that's gone through it
could really understand it.
And so I started my company,
Healthy, Happy, Hip,
and I started offering
them courses, and retreats,
and all sorts of programs to
help people with this issue.
And then I wrote this book,
"Busy, Stressed, and Food
Obsessed," so that I
could help more people.
And I started
hosting a radio show
so I could interview other
health and wellness rock stars
and bring that knowledge
to my people, as well.
Now, the name of the
book is "Busy, Stressed,
and Food Obsessed," but
you can fill in the blank.
Are you wine obsessed?
Are you prescription
drug obsessed?
We all use these
things to distract.
I didn't want to
think about my life,
and originally I
distracted with being busy.
Later on, I
distracted with food.
Many of us are distracting.
What are you distracting with?
So how do you not
end up like me?
Don't do what I did.
Don't ignore your warnings.
Your body is talking to you.
When something's wrong, it
means you need to listen,
or you'll end up
injured or sick.
Don't live in stress
mode all the time.
We're not supposed to do that.
We need to bring it down.
Take a break.
Don't isolate yourself.
Surround yourself
with friends, support,
and don't sacrifice that
fun and tranquility.
It nourishes your soul in a
way that nothing else can.
Connect your own dots.
Investigate.
What's going on in your life?
What's working for you?
What's not?
Do these experiments.
What happens if I
eat differently?
What happens if I go to
bed a little bit earlier?
What happens if I remove
the sugar from my life?
And look inside.
Look at your own baggage.
I was holding onto that stuff.
I'm not smart enough.
I have to suck it up.
I'm not a quitter.
I want to be someone.
I thought it was trying
to make my parents happy,
but it was my own stuff.
In some ways, you guys
have it much easier now.
You can work from anywhere.
You've got role models.
You've got mentors.
You've got this amazing
startup culture.
You've got tools, and
apps, and coffee bars.
It's really fun.
But in a lot of ways
it's harder now.
You've got social media
coming at you from everywhere.
And the fact that you
can work from anywhere--
you're more reachable than ever.
You guys-- you can't turn it
off for a minute, can you?
We live in this
frenetic, crazy culture.
Everybody wants
instant gratification,
and we really don't know how to
turn off that adrenaline rush.
But that is why it is
more important than ever
for you to slow down and listen
to what your body wants to say.
Let your body know that
it is not in danger.
you have a choice in how
you want to respond to this
environment that you are in.
Don't be afraid of the feelings.
I used to run as far as
I could away from them.
Now I invite them to tea.
I listen.
What are you here
to teach me today?
What can I learn from you today?
I know how hard it
is to bring it down,
and I designed a little one
minute tool for my clients
that I'm going to share
with you really quickly.
If you have a phone
or a book, grab it.
Anything rectangular will do.
And you're going
to work with me.
I'm going to give
you a quick demo.
We're going to say
in, hold, out, hold.
Touching something makes
a really big difference.
In, hold, out, hold, and then
we're going to slow it down.
In, hold, out, hold.
And then we're going
to close our eyes
and say the words to ourselves.
I'll demo it once, and then
you can all do it with me.
That was roughly 30 seconds.
Doing it for one minute
literally can bring your body
out of stress mode,
can clear your brain
and set you up for a
meditation practice.
For those of you who did it,
did it take your mind away
for just a second?
The combination of the tactile
touch and the saying in,
hold, out to yourself
seems to work very well
for people who have trouble
quieting their brain.
So in 2004, 18 years after we
started Lewtan Technologies,
we sold it.
And I'm very grateful to say we
made a lot of money doing so.
And I know that doesn't
always work out that way,
so I'm particularly
appreciative.
Couple of years
later, Stuart went on
and founded another business,
another tech company
called Zintro.
I went on, eventually
started my business,
Healthy, Happy, and Hip.
Two of my kids so far
work in tech already,
and my third is in
college, and she'll
end up in tech, too, no doubt--
maybe even here.
I'm not going to lie to you.
I'm still really busy.
I'm really busy, and I'm
doing a lot of cool things.
And that overwork
kind of mentality--
it definitely creeps up--
that workaholic thing.
And I have to really
be careful about it,
but I'll never ever
go back to that place.
I will never let myself ever
get back to that place--
that dark, dark place--
and I'll tell you why.
Every single day, I take
time to look inside.
I take time to slow down
to connect with my body,
with my mind, with my
spirit, and ask them,
what do you need to be OK?
And I listen.
And when I need to rest,
I rest, and I fill my body
with the most wonderful,
highest quality foods
that I can get my hands on.
And I don't obsess about
food anymore because I'm
filling my life with
joy, and with friendship,
and all those yummy
things that nourish us.
But the most important
lesson that I have learned--
the most important lesson that
I want to leave you with today--
is that I know
for sure that I am
and that I always
have been good enough.
And so are you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm happy to take any
questions if anybody has any.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
LISA LEWTAN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
coming here and talking
about your book.
I really look forward
to reading it.
So yesterday, last
night, I told my wife,
oh, there is this person coming
who wrote an amazing book,
and I looked up the
reviews on Amazon.
And there's something
about sugar,
and food as an obsession,
and mindful eating,
and blah, blah, blah.
And she's like, oh,
that sounds interesting.
What is the book about?
And I said, well, I don't know.
I'll find out.
So my question for you is,
when I meet family or friends
and I say, hey, I read
this amazing book,
I think you would also enjoy
it, and they say, that's great,
what is it about?
It's about?
How do you summarize it?
LISA LEWTAN: So that's
a great question,
and I really focused
on one part of the book
because I felt like
it was something
that you all could really
relate to really well-- this
busy, stressed.
And that's how I ended up
being in this field of health
and wellness.
And the book shares a lot of my
personal stories and struggles,
but it gives you a
step by step strategy
for looking inside
and experimenting
with your own mind and body to
understand who am I as a person
and who am I as
an eater, and how
to experiment to find out what
is going to make you personally
thrive.
Now, because I do
work a lot with food,
I did talk about food a
lot, but as I mentioned,
this could really apply
to just about anything.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]